make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay uh so we are a couple weeks out
from
the release of the playstation 5 and
miles morales spider-man uh spider-man
miles morales i guess is what they're
calling it whatever it is the spider-man
2 game uh and here's the thing okay
i'm actually kind of sad about this uh
myself and mariah have not pre-ordered
like we didn't get a chance to pre-order
the ps5 right now the pre-orders
were out like that like it was it was
insane uh so here's the deal
are there any members of the rob core in
columbus ohio
that can hook up myself and mariah with
playstation 5's right i'll give you like
an extra 200 bucks
plus the cost of the playstation 5's if
you can hook us up uh that would be
awesome
right that'd be that'd be super cool if
you can send me an email rob at comments
explaining.com
that would be amazing i don't know if
any of you guys can uh we'll even go as
far as cleveland if we have to
but uh that'd be awesome if you guys
could right so um
it's been a little while since we
covered miles morales right we covered
the first two and i think we did it like
three years ago so we're gonna do a
little bit of catch-up here for people
who are
are really uncertain and who are kind of
lagging behind in the midst of all this
so miles morales becoming spider-man
came out of what was basically like
cataclysm to a degree right it was it
was basically this great big huge story
arc in
in the ultimate universe where that
version of spider-man had died right so
a little bit of explanation here the
ultimate universe was launched in 2000
and it was the answer to the question
what would it look like if superheroes
existed in the real world right a more
modern depiction of superheroes as we
know them in marvel comics the ultimate
universe was hugely popular and it was
basically launched with ultimate
spider-man right with peter parker now
when peter parker died
spider-man fans were pissed right they
were so mad because
they love that version of spider-man and
as we know as comic book fans we don't
really like it when things change right
we like things to stay the same forever
and ever and ever because when things
are different
it takes us getting used to it again and
we just don't want to have to go through
all that
you know we got we're old people right
we just get stuck in our ways and the
results of this
is that when miles morales initially
came onto the scene there was a lot of
hate for the character of miles the
funny thing is he's hugely popular now
so much so that like one he's got his
own game and two i've heard nothing but
people being excited about the new miles
morales game right so as with most
things in comics
give it time and you may end up finding
that you like it but the the whole thing
behind this
is that in the early days and kind of in
the beginning of this miles morales
having been
bitten by a spider that gave him
radioactive powers in much the same way
that peter parker did was met with a lot
of backlash in the
ultimate comics universe right like in
the actual comics themselves because
peter parker had like
just died and then miles you know in
order to honor the memory of peter went
out and got a spider-man suit and then
was like okay
uh let's let's be spider-man right he
was met by like nick fury he was met by
uh jessica drew
or whatever you want to call her
basically the ultimate universe version
of spider-girl spider-woman and uh and
they were kind of like you can't do this
right like you're disrespecting the
memory of peter but the reality was that
miles believed that he was honoring the
memory of peter
right he believed he was doing the right
thing and so ultimately he ended up
getting the blessing of nick fury and
then this led to the introduction of the
prowler right the prowler was a
character who had already been around
and the prowler was basically uh the
the uncle of miles morales uh he was
basically aaron right and
the idea behind this was that you ended
up having uh miles basically allying
himself with aaron uh out of uh you know
as
part of aaron's request now when miles
sort of realized and the things were a
little sketchy here that's when all this
kind of started popping off right but
this this really is kind of like when
the two of them first start teaming up
we as the reader knew
that aaron was a bad guy right like we
knew he was basically a villain he was
one of the most wanted men in the united
states and in fact he was wanted by
interpol
and the fbi right like it was a huge
deal again it's probably one of the best
thieves if not the best thief in the
entirety of the ultimate universe he was
kind of a big deal now with him and
miles teaming up for the first time this
involves them going after a guy by the
name of
scorpion in marvel in the ultimate
universe you had two versions of the
scorpion character and you're probably
familiar with him from like maybe
spider-man the animated series back in
the 90s or comic books or whatever the
case is
but the scorpion that you initially saw
in ultimate comics was part of the
ultimate universe line of the clone saga
right like cloning peter parker that's
where you know the jessica character
came from and so on but the scorpion was
a clone of peter parker right so that
was kind of like that version that we
saw
i wouldn't go as far as to say he was
hugely popular i honestly didn't really
enjoy the whole concept but the thing
about this is that this version of
scorpion that we see here
is the guy who's actually named maximus
gargan right so his name is almost
identical to the one from the main
marvel universe
max gargan the difference here is that
unlike matt gargan and the maine marvel
universe who's just a guy who's a
criminal uh and then in the ultimate
universe maximus gargan was basically a
mexican
crime lord is essentially what he was he
was like a mexican drug kingpin but he
was working for
prowler and so essentially you had this
kind of exchange that was supposed to go
on between the two of them but basically
maximus gargan ended up turning on the
prowler it led into a great big huge
fight prowler basically got out of there
and then maximus has come here to new
york city in order to make himself a
kingpin
and because of the fact that he was able
to overcome prowler before the
indication is he can do it again right
so he's not too worried about the
prowler's character
but that's why they're here is because
aaron is trying to get rid of maximus or
trying to get rid of scorpion because
scorpion's encroaching on his turf
the the the idea that he's pitching to
miles morales is he's a bad guy
right so we got to get rid of bad guys
so he's essentially using miles desire
to be a hero
in order to effectively turn miles into
his own enforcer
is really kind of what's happening here
but scorpion showing up here and just
being like okay so like you know this is
my this this is my spot now right like
i'm taking over this like i was a guy
who operated in mexico that's true but
like now i want to swim with the bigger
fish right and so i'm taking the
entirety of new york over
i'm going to become its new kingpin the
the funny thing about this is that he's
immediately met
by aaron right he's immediately met by
the prowler and in turn the power is
like okay so like you gotta go
right you gotta you gotta go now the
response of of scorpion is like you
still owe me payment right like you
still owe me for
our last deal that went down technically
that's true that
that when that deal initially went down
that aaron was the one who refused to
love to his end of the bargain now he
did so under the auspices that scorpion
tried to double cross him
right and saying like you forfeited your
share of this whole thing when he tried
to double cross me but technically a
deal is a deal and so the result of this
is that
you know scorpion's here to kind of call
in his in and take out the prowler if he
can and then take over new york himself
now of course
this leads to spider-man jumping in now
there are questions that you're most
likely asking here right
where are characters like daredevil or
like luke cage
or heroes for hire or any of the number
of ground-level heroes that we see
in new york that could easily respond to
a threat like this the reality of the
ultimate universe guys is that it was
designed to be a far more stripped down
version
of the main marvel universe the main
marvel universe just to give you
perspective
had like thousands of mutants who had
appeared over the course of marvel's
publication history and those are the
ones that they focus on for any real
measure of time when you take into
account the one-offs the ones who
appeared for like a single story then
you're starting to get into the hundreds
of thousands right there were just you
know
so many different mutants that had
appeared and so you take that and you
expand it to like the almost
never-ending roster of avengers you add
in things like
the midnight suns right you add in like
you know dr strange's black ops
defenders team from like the 1990s right
they carried out like all these secret
missions and things like that it was
super cool it was an awesome concept it
was terribly executed but it was an
awesome concept but you take all these
things and you throwing it in and what
you end up in the main marvel universe
you end up with this just
hugely expansive landscape of heroes and
it's insanely difficult to keep up with
it all the ultimate universe wanted to
correct that
right so you have like the ultimates
you've got the fantastic four you've got
the x-men you got spider-man and that's
basically it but you see other
characters kind of pop in and out but
you weren't really seeing like ultimate
comics blade
right you weren't really seeing that you
weren't really seeing like ultimate
comics werewolf by night
you weren't really seeing any of that
stuff right any of like these characters
that would have been interesting to see
instead it was designed to be
super closed down i would say that
overall in terms of
individual publications right individual
comic book lines i think you
may be capped out at 20 comics over the
course of the ultimate universe's
lifespan
and i'd say that's probably about it if
that right it was very very very very
small
seeing other characters would happen in
other characters comics things like that
right so just just
one of the you know kind of an answer to
that question you know why don't we see
a lot more going on here uh because it's
not designed to be
overly huge right it's one of the great
things about the ultimate universe but
of course this is when things pop
off basically you know everybody pulls
guns guns blazing shots firing
everything's going all to pieces now
this is when we kind of get reminded a
little bit of the of the scorpions
powers right and make sure you guys
check
down in the description just kind of a
reminder make sure you check down in the
description
you'll find uh ultimate spider-man uh
really the first two videos that we did
volumes one and two you'll find that
down there so you can get caught up and
you won't feel like you're just kind of
flying in and out of nowhere but uh but
the idea behind scorpion is that he has
enhanced durability and enhanced
strength now he's not completely
invulnerable and he doesn't have like
super human strength right where he's
like equal to the incredible hulk and
strength or anything like that he's just
kind of got enhanced abilities but there
are enough to where he can easily hold
his own against like you know
being shot at or being stabbed or
something along those lines right so he
doesn't really have luke cage's skin
but something reasonably close to it the
other part of this is that given his
enhanced abilities he also was able to
go toe-to-toe with miles morales but the
reason why this happens
is because miles is still learning about
his powers right he's still learning
what he's capable of now a lot of miles
ability to expand beyond his existing
horizons will actually come
in the first spider-man story which we
will cover that's basically it was it
was really cool it was when bendis
basically told all the miles morales
haters to shut up when they were like
he's not really spider-man venice
literally wrote a story where peter
parker from the main marvel universe and
miles morales from the ultimate universe
and and peter parker is like who cares
what the world says
uh i think you're a great spider-man go
forward right and it's basically ben is
saying hey i know you guys
some of you guys out there don't like
miles morales tough luck and then just
like
continuing to write the story it was
amazing it was a hilarious response to
the haters but the
the funny thing about this is that miles
is learning his powers
and so when it comes to somebody like
peter but if we look at like even the
ultimate universe comics version of
spider-man peter parker or you look at
the main marvel
universe version of spider-man peter
parker the important thing is that in
the early days he had his learning
he had his process where he learned his
powers but as time went on it started to
become second nature to where he could
just react and instinctively know what
he needs to do you know that's one of
the things that kind of came out of dan
slot's run
is when he was talking about why why
spider-man would crack jokes all the
time
because where you kind of looked at it
and saw spider-man as almost kind of a
nonsensical character you know when he
was engaging in in fights and didn't
really seem to be taking it seriously
the reason why he would crack jokes is
because he wanted to make the villains
think he wasn't taking them seriously
and that in turn would piss them off and
the angrier they got the less focused
they became
and the easier it would be for peter
parker to take them out that's one of
the things that he kind of learned over
the course of his time
as spider-man with miles morales it'll
be much the same way that as we cover
these comics you'll quite literally see
miles become better at being spider-man
but in these early comics here in this
third volume of his original run
he doesn't really know what he's doing
he doesn't really have any official
training and that's really what he was
told by nick fury when nick fury
sanctioned him as being spider-man he's
like you're on your own to figure out
how to be a superhero we're not going to
train you right we're not going to give
you like official training at least not
at the moment we're not going to do any
of that right like you just got to
become the best version of spider-man
that you can
on your own and if you really are meant
to be a great spider-man then you will
become one if not
then you'll probably suck and you'll
probably end up getting killed best of
luck and that was basically it
it was kind of a dick move but you know
ultimately one of the things that miles
ends up doing
is underestimating uh scorpion right in
the sense that he's able to overcome him
for a minute and where aaron wants to
get his revenge on
on scorpion the response of miles is no
it's one thing to stop a criminal it's
another to go out of your way and try to
kill the guy
right like that's not going to do
anybody any good and and ultimately
miles
ends up intending to kind of walk away
now scorpion wakes up scorpion attacks
miles miles goes invisible he attacks
scorpion again
and then when miles turns his back
scorpion gets away and so it's one of
these things where
he's constantly underestimating the
villains that he faces off against but
that's because he simply hasn't learned
that you have to make sure that they're
knocked out right like you know that's
that's one of the things that peter kind
of learned right as time went on that
like as he would face off against
different villains he would realize just
because they look like they're knocked
out doesn't mean they are right you just
gotta you gotta pummel them a few extra
times or you gotta
you know smack them around a little bit
more than you normally would and then
you know then they'll be knocked out and
that'll
that'll basically be it you know you
gotta slap him around a bit is is kind
of what what peter parker would do but
of course this leads to
to of course you know miles morales
tracking down uh tracking down scorpion
going to attack him again
and then using his uh his venom blast
right to essentially incapacitate him
this kind of venom shock
ability that he has to incapacitate uh
scorpion and then handing scorpion over
to the cops now the response to the
police officers
is to initially try to arrest miles
morales and that is the way his comics
were early in the early days right and
it wasn't really like a racial thing it
wasn't like he's wearing a black
spider-man costume
obviously he's black get him it wasn't
necessarily like that
it was this idea that they didn't know
him like when peter parker first showed
up on the scene
in a lot of ways it was kind of a
welcoming thing now a lot of that was
because of the fact that
it was spider-man right and nobody wants
to really read comics where the world
hates spider-man and then two
uh because it was kind of the launch of
the ultimate universe right so it was
designed to be kind of a celebratory
run you know this this kind of
celebratory inaugural run in peter now
he did run into a whole bunch of
problems and there were times when
society was kind of like ah
you know but nonetheless you know with
miles more morales in a lot of ways
the the writing the how the cops are
depicted here is designed to kind of
depict the naysayers right in the sense
that he's not spider-man we don't really
know what's going on here but
get rid of him you know he's not legit
uh and so as a result of that of course
he makes himself invisible and ends up
taking off
right ends up you know kind of going
back to where aaron and them were
looking to find aaron and aaron
basically disappeared now the next day
you end up getting miles meeting up with
genki right meeting up with genki lee
the two of them kind of talking
you know and and he's like dude you
busted like maximus right you busted a
he busted the scorpion like he's this
this huge thing and then that's when he
starts talking to uh to his uncle aaron
and his uncle aaron's like he's like
where'd you go he's like i'm gonna go
get some rest are you okay and
you know it's like okay like we're just
getting started right like we're gonna
get back to this again
and and miles initial idea is no like i
don't want to be involved in this right
and that's when aaron kind of breaks out
that that blackmail card in the sense of
like i wanted like then maybe i should
hit up your dad right maybe i should
tell your dad what's going on now that's
a little bit of backstory that we
haven't really explained yet the idea
was that aaron
of course has kind of always been a
criminal his whole life uh it started
out with him just kind of getting into
mischief when he was younger and then
graduating into you know more more
intense and and uh more not really
violent
uh but more serious crimes the father of
miles
was involved in that to a degree but
eventually went his own separate way
right he kind of went you know
basically went on the right path kind of
corrected himself and got himself into a
better place the result of this is that
uh the father miles does not like aaron
and he does not want aaron to have any
involvement in miles life and he's made
that clear to miles right like do not
spend time with your uncle he's a bad
guy right like he's a criminal like if
you follow him like he will get you into
trouble he doesn't care about anybody he
doesn't care about anything if he can if
he
leads you to believe that he cares about
you it's because he's duping you right
like he's using you for his own ends and
so that's one of the things that kind of
went on here is that miles
knew he wasn't really supposed to be
spending time with aaron but he has been
anyway the other part of this is that
mile's parents don't know anything about
his powers right they don't know that
he's spider-man
and so he's kind of trying to keep this
secret from them now it's one of these
things where aaron
knows this and then uses it against him
and says i mean we can we can go in
there right now right when miles meets
him later on he's like we can go in
there right now and i can just tell them
everything that's going on miles
responses no fine like i'll meet with
you
the same place as last time and so when
the two of them end up meeting up
together
miles shows up and says this is not
gonna happen you're like i'll tell my
parents if i need to but here's what's
gonna go on you're gonna leave town
right like you are really a bad person
you're every bit as bad as my dad said
you were
right like you really don't care about
anybody but yourself like you don't come
near me you don't come near my parents
right now this was important for miles
this was a hugely important moment for
miles morales and the reason why is
because for his character
the way he was originally written he
wasn't necessarily a people pleaser but
he had this desire
to connect with his uncle aaron and the
fact that he was able to connect to a
degree
even when he was younger and he spent
time with him knowing that he wasn't
necessarily supposed to you know in this
moment right now
spending time with his uncle aaron and
trying to to get to you know get to know
him on a more
personal level is compounded and made
difficult by the fact that aaron really
is a bad guy and so coming to him with
miles morales being
largely a a character who lacked a lot
of confidence in himself right he locked
confidence in himself what he was
capable of and what he could achieve to
in turn
come along and to go against someone
somebody like the prowler who despite
not having
the powers of spider-man is wildly
capable of going toe-to-toe with one uh
is you know
he's basically saying like you're gonna
leave here right like you're gonna leave
this town you're never gonna talk to me
or my parents again
you know and and it's one of these
things where where power is like fine
like if you want to play with the big
boys then you got to be ready and then
he in turn
attacks miles morales and this is not
easy fight for miles right using a
combination of all of his gadgetry his
sonics
all those things at his disposal he's
able to kind of get the get the upper
hand on miles
but one of the important things here is
that miles starts to gain more
confidence in his abilities and begins
to use his powers in the way that he's
supposed to right
making himself invisible using you know
using a sneak attack using subtlety
different things like that and that's
one of the important things to
understand is that when it comes to
someone like miles
what he lacks an experience he makes up
for in powers that peter parker simply
just didn't have
peter parker did not have a venom blast
he could not make himself invisible
right and so you know with with miles
the fact that he's still learning how to
fight this actually bends itself to his
favor right instead of being something
that can just enhance his existing
abilities
it can help him compensate for his lack
of experience right making himself
invisible and then coming back around
again and so he's able to to kind of get
the upper hand on aaron and actually
ends up damaging one of his gloves right
one of his power gloves and when that
happens of course the fight ends up
leading down into the street
where basically there's almost like this
massive record or this this city bus
you know kind of topples over when aaron
ends up blasting it right with his
gloves and that's really when miles
begins to get the bigger picture
that aaron really doesn't care about
anybody but himself that he really is
a tried and true villain and this is
also significant because one of the
biggest issues that miles had is he had
this desire to inherently see the good
in everybody and while that's not
necessarily a bad thing
that kind of naivety can really cause
you problems later on down the line
right the belief that people are
inherently good and if they end up doing
bad things it's because they were in a
rough spot but they want to become good
people that can cost
lives and that's what miles is learning
here that aaron isn't a guy who was just
down on his luck and ended up in a bad
spot and there's a way to reach him and
turn him back into a good guy he's just
a bad person
and the fact that he's willing to like
endanger the lives of a busload of
people
in order to to to get the upper hand in
a fight against miles morales
really shows the kind of person that he
is and so at that point miles morales
starts cutting loose right he starts
letting loose
and it's just like fun like like if
that's how we're gonna fight then let's
fight this is gonna be a knock down
dragon fight he uses his venom blast
starts you know starts literally hitting
aaron from every direction and getting
the upper hand the problem with this
is that in a split second aaron gets the
upper hand on on miles and goes to
attack him and seemingly does it with
the intention of killing him the problem
with this is the previous attack by
miles that damaged his glove
ends up coming home to roost when the
whole thing explodes right it's like a
bomb going off and when that happens
it kills aaron right it looks like it
kills aaron and so it's just kind of
like the last little word
that miles gets here from aaron is like
look at that
right you're just like me you don't care
who you kill
as long as you come out on top it's just
this crushing response
to miles effectively getting his uncle
killed or
seemingly getting his uncle killed with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
end uh if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]